I've been broadcasting the whole time.
There's no privacy here, man.
Magic wand.
Look at the quick one.
Twitch viewers out here like, it's not a stream unless we
have 20 minutes of tech support.
We did have 20 minutes of tech support.
Yes.
Yeah, but if we were on YouTube, nobody would have seen it.
They get to listen to 20 minutes of the loading screen.
Look at him.
And they can just, you know, figure that there was probably
something that went wrong.
and it like worked on you oh what did you get the wand from
i want a wand oh what it's because watch this how'd you get
the wand tempest oh come over here
there's like wands here oh free ones free ones oh i love
free ones yeah free ones look Where do you get a stick from
the tree?
There should be one that's broke that you can break off.
Up dog.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There should be more sticks, right?
Error.
Oh, you can bump.
Up dog.
Oh!
Contract explode enemies with piss.
That doesn't sound very magical.
Well, if it's magical piss it is.
Magical piss.
Are these like...
I'm not making that a wizard.
No, we'll find you one.
We'll find you one.
We'll get you one.
Yeah, it's like a dungeon crawler type thing.
Oh my god, I wasn't looking forward to getting like bullied
again.
I mean, there is friendly fire like Tempest.
Wait.
Tempest.
Where?
Oh shit.
Tempest.
Yes, the power of the four wins.
How do I drop my, my wand?
it to neemies oh god there is fall damage everybody sell the
wand of winds no this is my damage oh wait you can get like
prettier wands you can get like special ones here later on
oh and a mystery egg i want a mystery egg wait there's a
bottom fairy we can eat it oh she's talking to me we can we
can eat the fairy what if the mystery egg is a cute pet hold
oh yeah it's true a companion you're familiar what if we can
kill him and take his stuff maybe another one grew up too It
says you can steal coins.
Four of us are all we can really do is say up dog and fly
me.
My money.
Okay, so like...
I'm gonna look for another tree.
Wait, look what I can do.
Wait, what did he do?
Wait, how do I use this?
Did you kick it?
She pad.
Oh wait, sorry.
I'm sorry!
He can't...
So you put that away.
Oh!
That's the...
What?
You hear that?
That's amazing.
Oh my god!
That's beautiful!
Thank you.
Play, play as the song.
Ah!
It's a frog.
What's his name?
Frog first?
Oh my god!
What can I do with this?
Wait, what can I do with this?
I'm going to go ahead and watch this.
i don't know if i want to find out what are you doing to me
oh look i can lift doki what all right let's go what does it
happen to you oh wait how far does this place go i can be in
a backpack now i can hear it mimi i sold my wand i thought
it might spawn a new wand but you sold your wand but now i
don't have one so how about we become the musicians okay
follow me you guys guys press Press V.
Did we really V?
V.
What are you doing to V?
Help!
Okay.
That's what V does.
So apparently...
Oh, okay.
That's what V does.
Oh.
Here, I'll grab it.
Wait, there's a wand right here.
Holding that frog.
Where?
Oh.
I picked it up off the floor.
Grab it.
No, it's not.
Take it, take it.
The way to go.
Right here, right here!
Right down my feet.
Did it grow?
Where did Tara use...
Where did her make sano?
Oh!
Oh, we're teleporting!
We're teleporting!
Are you going!
Wait you...
Did anyone look at the contract?
What happened?
What happened to me?
Oh,
we're fine.
We're okay.
We just saw your friends.
Do you teleport хотя?
Oh, that's me.
Wait, my frog came with me!
Oh, shit.
Well, our wards came with us, too.
I'll put everybody up.
Oh, nice.
Kind of magic playing.
Uh, song on your mom.
Oh, that's my favorite wand.
How did you know?
I want to see you.
What are we doing in this game?
What do we do, actually?
You now.
Oculus!
Oculus.
You have to get quota.
It's like lethal.
Yeah, yeah, but like...
I didn't read our job description.
Did anyone read what our contract wanted us to do?
We have to explode swine with piss and steal at least two
gold.
I forget what the third one was.
Who did that, Tempest?
No, not me!
That me!
I don't even have a wand!
Oops.
Wait, plus five.
Oh, you get money by breaking things.
You get money by breaking things.
I have.
That is.
All right, so where's Zelda?
Yeah, if you assault those boxes, it seems to do things.
I feel like a freaking muggle here.
I can't do anything.
Who did that?
Powdered crystal.
That's Tempest.
Does that stash me?
Oh.
Arrow.
But how do we break things with pitch?
This is beautiful.
Thank you.
Yellow Tempest.
I don't know where.
Yeah, we need a different genre movie to break things with
kids.
Wait, it's kind of dark in here.
I have a lantern.
This is my brilliant show.
You do?
Yeah.
You're so smart!
I'm so intelligent!
Is there something up here?
I'm gonna throw this medieval cat.
Maybe drag it up there.
Oh.
What?
We got a candle.
Wait, how is stuff he gonna...
Guys!
There's a thing running around!
There's a guy in there!
Bring it, bring it on!
Yeah!
There's something in here.
There was a little...
There was a green man.
There was a green man!
Someone... Are you sure it's not you?
You're technically green.
I don't think so.
Are you sure you didn't see a mirror in it?
You know what they say?
The boy who cried wolf.
Well, you all regret it when...
the little man comes back when he comes back when he gets
you yeah when he gets you
oh i just i just i don't even touch it i mean i did touch it
that's all i did you got so much money from that i did oh
let's go wait how did you burn oh did you touch warp to
extraction oh maybe yeah with the thing on the floor wait
just go up or down oh wait i don't know victory interesting
we had to go back after the day ends or something oh i yeah
i think so okay oh my god is it the green man there was
something up there see where i don't know i thought it
looked like a frog see i told you oh my god look There's
something there!
Oh my god, there's bad guys!
Tempest!
Arrow!
We have a contract to Tempest them!
Yay!
Whoa!
That's a noise for her!
Who is that?
Tempest?
What?
Yay!
Well, I hate that.
Did you just turn me into one of those?
Holy shit!
I don't know.
How would it happen?
Did you get like hex?
That's awesome!
That's so funny.
That was disgusting.
Oh!
I found the green!
I thought you were coming and murder me.
Who is it?
Oh, it's a goblin!
I found it!
I told you!
Holy shit.
He's at the bottom of the stairs.
There's no fall damage, so we can jump down if we have to.
Oh, there's no one?
Okay, cool.
Yeah, there's no, yeah.
Oh.
If he crumbs up, give me, he comes up.
If he crumbs up.
Yeah.
Who is in here destroying everything?
There's some sort of, like, demonic altar?
I don't know.
Hold on, hold on.
I got this.
Oh, yeah.
Summon, you're summoning Song.
We need the sacrifice.
someone me oh yeah I killed a green man yeah oh my candle
went out that was spooky that is a little spooky it'll be a
yeah pretty awkward I don't know how to drop him though I
can't let go of my candle oh I can switch my oh he has a
middle mouse button it zooms out yeah yeah I was just doing
that whoa wait I have a A camera, a selfie cam.
Wait, you have a selfie camera?
Wait, how do you do that?
My middle mouse button does a selfie cam.
Oh, mine, like, shows my back.
If you hold it down, it does.
Whoa!
Guys, we have five and a half minutes left, just letting you
know.
Guys, come on, come on, come on.
I count four of us.
We're missing one person in this group.
Limu's probably working and doing a job.
See, Limu is on the ground.
Yeah.
Or she's cursed and like locked in the pits of hell.
We don't have enough.
We put that one person in the group project that does all
our work and we're just chilling.
We were doing research.
Oh, see, Lymo's here.
You got- Oh.
Oh.
That was a green person.
Peppist!
Wait, the green man is friendly.
Oh, he is?
Yeah, he's pretty chill.
He simply doesn't seem to like us.
Whoa
This looks significant somehow.
Yeah Probably I found a mystery egg, but you can I'm like
hitting this with my head and it's like So are there enemies
I found I found golem gunad look
Did you stash that?
did you steal my gun what the fuck wait guys can we unify
our magical power and cast arrow on this one I did already
hit it once but we can try okay okay okay
It gave me 10 points for hitting it once.
Oh, shit.
Okay, okay.
Get this.
Oh.
Oh, the coverage doesn't destroy itself.
Oh, what?
I don't know if we're gonna make it.
Arrow.
I got us $2.
I feel like...
Arrow.
Arrow is such a shitty spell.
I'm not pulling my weight, you guys.
This is like a weight.
Oh, my.
Amber.
Is this guy evil?
Oh!
No he's not dead!
He's not dead!
There's a bomb!
He's dropping money!
Oh, Q is how you drop stuff.
I'll take a torch.
Can I light things on fire now?
Oh, I can!
Wait, where'd that guy go?
I'll light him on fire.
Wait, let me test on you.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry to me.
I thought you were Doki.
No.
I'm setting everything on fire.
Okay, it was really bright, okay?
Don't talk.
Wow, you can't, you miss every time.
You miss.
You can't even cast a spell I think the goblin dude just
threw a bomb at me.
Yeah, he does that.
Yeah, he's quite rude.
What's this way?
Well, we're about to die, so I'm gonna go explore.
What's that?
Oh, I got jump scared by the candle holder.
I don't know what this is.
What's down there?
A new place?
Yeah.
Okay, I'll go down.
Oh.
There's no fall damage, so you'll be fine.
Nibi?
What happened?
What happened to her?
I don't know.
She just said I'll go down and then...
What did you...
You committed a crime.
I didn't do it.
We got...
You were the last person next to her.
Don't put her down there.
Don't put her down.
Don't worry.
Ahaydi, don't worry.
Oh, she, oh, that's why she jumped down and it reappeared
there.
I think that pit was a bottomless pit.
I think so.
Oh, no.
Well, Nimi, we're about to die anyway.
It's okay.
No, no, no, no.
We got this.
We have one minute to get $90.
Extract.
How do I extract?
We still need $90, man.
Are you extracting?
acting right now?
I don't know what that means.
It means going back home.
Oh!
Oh, I didn't realize that's what that was.
My bad.
Okay, so what are we going to do with the body?
Can we burn it?
We might.
What's this?
Oh, I'm watching people.
Oh, I'm pondering.
Whoa, I'm...
Is that limo?
When we leave?
When we leave.
Wait, wait, wait, extract, extract.
For real.
Yeah?
Okay, not all.
We have to wait for everybody.
Come, come, come, come, come.
They don't know we're here.
Oh, we're screwed.
Goodbye.
Oh, what a problem.
Wait, what does the ghost approaches mean?
It's okay.
We're fine.
We're about to go land, though.
It's okay.
We'll be alive.
What does the ghost...
Wait.
Oh, okay.
I made it.
Oh.
No.
We made it.
wait did we oh three players missed extraction oh i got
eaten by a ghost i don't think we made it we lost we lost
200 gold yeah we didn't make it we did we did we'll be fine
we'll be fine wait what what do the ghost look like now oh
we only have 22 personal gold well that's beans wait what
wait do i get it wait that means like the company takes 90
we only earn like 5% in the company takes 95 I think they
might have docked our earnings yeah but 22 of each we had
it's at 760 how do you cast a spell oh here but yeah I think
I think it's it might be that anything we get over is
spendable it's like I think it's like lethal company where
we have three nights we have the quota yeah and I think if
you don't get extracted am I dead no you're alive oh am I
alive what happened when you died I just died.
I fell down the hole.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, no, that's fair.
Maybe we earned gold based on our chaos.
You're here, though.
It died instantly.
There wasn't even anything down there.
I know.
You just, I turned around and you were dead on the ground.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe we should have stashed the gonads.
Oh, I stashed some stuff.
How do I get it out?
Yeah, how do I access to stash items?
Maybe you can give that man your balls?
Uh, excuse me?
I don't know how to open a shop.
You heard what a shop.
It's a jar complete.
Oh.
I don't know.
I don't know if you can sell things.
I don't know either.
Yeah, I have a fairy.
What's a dragon bone?
I mean, you could actually buy a dragon bone or an amber.
Wait, you can actually purchase the golem gonads.
He's got them here unless you just sell them.
Wait, I thought you were joking.
No, they are.
For real.
Yeah.
It looks like dates.
It was kind of hard to see in the game.
Dates.
Yeah, they look like little dates.
deal with chat why don't we get the items that we stashed
because i have the gonads and and if you didn't if you
didn't make it out you're not getting them i wonder what
other uh i wonder what other instruments we got a tambourine
how do i get rid of it nope i've tried getting A loot!
I'm up here.
Hi, I'm coming.
Up dog.
Hi, we're extracting guys.
We're going in on another job.
Okay, wait.
I still don't know how to get my inventory stuff.
I stash some things.
I'm coming.
It doesn't say.
Tempest.
Yeah.
Pass this.
Woohoo!
Oh wait, watch this.
Oh.
Watch what?
Press T, guys.
T?
O T.
Oh!
That's horror.
Yeah!
Oh yeah!
Let's go!
Good job!
This is this one.
You.
Hmm.
is this guys we have to think on what spell teams or yell
out the spell yell out the spell yell yell real loud yell
real good keep yelling tempest
okay I want to start it I want to start okay did we do it
right I want to see what other magics we can do I think we
did.
I think so.
Yeah, we did great.
Yeah, yeah.
I think we're doing a good job, guys.
Yeah, I think so too.
Did we share our money?
I don't know.
I just spent some on a torch so that we could see.
Oh, I have a handle too.
Oh, I think we- I wonder, I bet you I can use these to set
things on fire.
Hold on.
Wait, I have $12 left.
Who spent my fucking money?
Oh, it is a collective money.
I spent it on a torch.
Sorry.
Ew.
magic wait what's this phoenix feather oh i'm going left i'm
going up i'm going high ground that's where they stash all
their jewelry whoa what was that who's that oh wait that's
stuffy i was the wizard who resides in this castle.
Arrow.
Please!
Oh.
I can't.
So we just destroy stuff.
We just kind of...
Yeah, it's anti-repo.
Anti-repo.
You destroy everything instead of collect it.
Oh, what's that guy?
Oh, arrow.
Arrow.
Oh, how could you miss tempest i'm gonna beat him up tempest
yeah we're making cash fast do i have a a oh set it on five
no hold on hold on because we get money if we set it on five
i don't know i'm trying to say hold on let me try and use
this let me try and use this oh oh oh okay oh oh oh yeah we
got money a he works arrow wait did you kill that guy oh
wait no tempest Oh my god, he's a...
Oh!
What the?
He's throwing bombs!
Arrow.
Oh, he is, no, he is taking damage.
Blow his bombs on him.
Oh, blow his bombs on him.
It's okay, he can't hurt us until it's 10 minutes.
Arrow.
He's gone.
He's trying to hurt us, though.
Yeah, but apparently Lama said by a 10 minute.
They bring out the swords.
Oh, they bring out swords!
Yeah, yeah.
I took damage though.
Arrow!
Sorry, you said in front of my epic magic.
Oh, she's dead!
Oh!
She's dead!
Me?
Oh!
I wasn't me!
Mitt, that's...
That's two deaths, Mitt.
No!
Ah!
It's...
It's very weird that every time I...
No, she's alive!
Look at her!
Look at her go!
She's alive!
Every time I walk over here...
No, she's alive!
She's alive!
Snuffy, if you are alive, stay arrow.
Do you see what she's doing right now?
Yeah, yeah, what is she doing?
What is she doing?
Breaking it down, obviously.
Are we going to weekend at Bernie's list?
I'm not even holding her, are you?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, you are holding her.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
I'll be the...
You'll be the voice.
Oh, I'm getting injured by her.
Stop!
It's like, it's karma.
We're going to weekend at Snuffy's list.
I didn't do anything.
Wait.
Um, guys, I'm Stuffy, and, um, I'm a raccoon.
Guys...
She's just a raccoon.
That's all she is.
I'm a sexy raccoon.
Oh, what just happened?
Oh.
What does that mean?
I don't know.
We stepped into some little...
There's orbs.
Grab the orbs.
Oh, Arrow!
Arrow!
Wait, I'm stuck.
Oh my god.
I've stuck you with the life.
You don't know what to do.
No, she wouldn't!
Wait, I got one of them.
Wait, I've dug this.
I've dug this.
I've dug what?
No, this, this.
Do you see the orb?
Grab the orb.
I don't see an orb.
Oh my god.
I think that's what I, we can't get out.
Oh my god, we're gonna die.
There's literally no orb.
It is.
I see it's right here.
Then you get it.
Oh.
I think we're fine.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, no, no, no, okay, he's scared.
Oh, there's one up there, there's one up there.
Okay, there, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah, I think we're gonna go up.
Up dog.
Yes.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh!
Ooh!
I'm okay.
Okay, I found another one, I found another one.
Hold on, where is it?
Where is it?
Oh, I see it, I see it, I see it, I see it.
I got it.
Uh, there's one, there's one, there's one up here, there's
one up here, but the...
Yeah, I think that's last one.
That's last one.
No, there's four out of seven.
Oh no man if only we had a third player here right now if
only if only someone I wasn't me it wasn't me Wait I there's
another one over here Oh my god oops wait I think it's over
Oh nope that's just noob Do you see her acting like this on
your screen or She's just dead That's all I see.
That's all I see.
It's just me then.
Oh, we can do it again.
We can do it again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have to...
Oh, no.
Ouch, she's killing me though.
She's killing me, for real.
The ghost.
Okay, all right.
Wait.
I got two.
Uh, where are the houses?
Oh, okay.
How the hell do you get over to these?
Oh.
Tempest!
I don't think we should do this one.
I think we should find the extraction.
I am not okay right now.
Ouch.
Where is he?
Where's what?
Where's the mimic?
Oh, it went over here next to...
Yeah, no, no, do not get...
Don't get near it.
Okay.
I just can't stop watching Snuffy.
What is she doing on your screen?
She's currently under the ground.
Like, she's just...
She's really glitching out, like, crazy for me.
But, and to get close to her, she, like, hurts me because
she's, like, a weapon.
What?
Get away from me!
Get away!
Hello?
okay oh you guys want to help us with this wait this would
be great oh my gosh so what happened was i walked over and
then a dead snuffy was next to men which was pretty
suspicious because that's two out of two of dead bodies next
to men
guys we gotta give her a proper mario no no no no no no okay
you guys we're gonna press this thing dance around the body
to honor her.
Arrow.
It's not really fucking hurt.
That's a way 50% of my life.
I know, I told you!
She's lethal!
She's like a weapon!
Use it on the goblin, use it on the goblin!
Yeah, use it on him.
It doesn't hurt me, because I didn't commit any crime.
Oh my God.
Also, be careful, because, uh, men and I encountered a
mimic, and we don't know where he went.
I know where he went.
It's literally right here.
I told you right here right here
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
Hi, it's not me Don't be the fucking door is locked What did
you do?
What did you do?
No, no, no, no Okay, so you guys don't worry don't we were
Don't worry there's a timer here you see that little timer
there our ends and nothing bad will happen to us i don't
know it's going crazy unless we get hit by the threshing oh
god wait i can't hear you stop me because everyone else is
so loud oh i love the doors open what was that they have two
minutes oh let's go let's leave they gotta just find the
extraction Should we take the bodies with us?
That is a bad room.
Wait, did I fully left?
Aww.
I'm up the stairs.
Come on.
Oh my god, you fully booked it.
Okay, so Snuffy's body is right over there next to the jar.
Pick Snuffy.
Wait, wait, no.
Okay, Snuffy.
She almost killed me.
I got mint.
Is my body got collision?
It's like, it's an actual...
Oh my god.
I'm like a hairy girl.
I'm like a wild dog.
Oh my god.
No!
I didn't marry her before!
Put me down!
Just put me down!
Oh my god!
No, they're cheating!
Don't worry, I'm the only one she does in here because she
knows I didn't commit a crime.
It's an unexpected twist of fate.
My body's gonna get revenge on everyone.
How did you die?
I flew off.
Like, I'm just blooming off this tower.
Oh, I think that was my fault.
I am blessed.
Break out.
I think so.
Oh He's a guy.
Oh, he's got a bomb Oh, oh
50 seconds Get in Oh Oh my god Wow Yeah
Hey, Doki, how did you?
Did you get killed by him?
Oh my god, no, no, no, no Oh, you got a god by a bomb Oh!
Arrows!
This is not an extraction!
I'm gonna die!
It's not an extraction?
Run!
No, it's not an extraction?
It's time for the moment they get here.
We thought it was safety.
It was not safety.
Oh.
What do we do?
I thought it was a warped extraction then.
Oh, wait.
I wasn't where you did that war.
Wait, this is the wrong way, I think.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, that's it.
The ghost!
The ghost is here!
I want to see the ghost.
The ghost approaches.
I think...
I think I saw the ghost.
Ow.
Ow!
Oh, hey!
Oh, the ghost is pretty!
Oh!
Oopsie!
So, uh...
Oh, dear.
Oh!
No way!
We have wizards, we have to lock in.
Yeah, wizards, we have to lock in.
We've got this, it's fine.
Oh, are you okay, Lymo?
Come here.
Oh, man.
Come here, Nymo.
Come on.
I thought it was an extraction because I didn't read it, but
no, it worked us straight into a gigantic pseudo-fucking
armor.
Wait, that wasn't the extraction?
but you're being weird oh it's stuffy's body again how do
you do that i know now i just feel like this is how it
should be i had so much i had so much to give i didn't do
that i don't know i was just bored with rubber balls it's
okay we definitely got it this time oh my god my god my leg
I'm sorry someone start the extraction I'll just be lying
here Okay we got this guys Wait oh wait hold on I need my I
need a wand Oh oh oh okay Oh I can't grab a wand I can't
activate it I can't cancel it Wait oh I got it I got it I
got it I got it
Another torch I want to burn everything I'm depressed from
our crippling debt Wait you can take them off the walls I'm
so depressed Oh, you can get them from the walls?
Come on.
You'll be all right.
Distry egg.
Wait.
It said I just said pitch.
Arrow.
Come on.
Frankie's arrow.
Catch them on.
Arrow.
Catch them under fire.
We're not in debt.
We still have a positive.
We had minus 25.
Oh, whoops.
That's not right.
not right all right tempest arrow tempest is tempest or
arrow more powerful a phoenix what does it do i don't
actually know what any of the earnings i know i have this
egg and i can't let go of it now my nine to five was your
job yeah it's my baby my baby egg my baby egg yeah i can't
let go of this egg.
I still don't even know.
I still don't know where the stash items go.
Oh, bye-bye.
Yeah, it feels good to grab it.
It's where we have to go, where it takes us back to the main
base.
There's nothing here.
It's a dead end.
I don't believe you.
What is that?
Oh, that's just one of us.
It was just really scary.
Oh!
Who is it a deadhead?
You just gotta jump.
You just gotta park Oh, I didn't even see that part.
You don't even have to jump.
You gotta take the jump.
Oh, okay.
Oh, hey, there's a candle.
Nice.
Alright.
There also is fall damage in this game.
Up dog.
Are you sure?
I didn't take fall damage.
I definitely do.
Yeah, I'll try.
Oh, not here, though.
Arrow.
Destroy, destroy.
Oh, it's magical in here.
Is there...
Are you okay down there?
Yeah, I come down.
Alright, I'm gonna take the stairs.
Oh!
Tempest.
I know I don't have to do this.
I just don't remember.
I mean, it's easier.
Yeah.
For sure.
Yes.
Oh, it's the demon room.
Oh, it's...
Oh, wait.
It was the extraction room, but...
This is the extraction room?
It was.
This is where we extracted first, remember?
Oh.
No, I don't remember, actually.
I actually don't know.
I just made that up.
Why are you telling lies on the internet?
Tempest.
Wait, it didn't do it.
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Wait, I got... I got back... What?
You got what?
What?
I got a bachelor's heart, look.
Look at this.
What is that?
Yeah, it's like...
We did it!
Yeah!
There's someone...
I think it must have been Lymo, I'm pretty sure.
She's the most competent player on our team.
I think we all sing.
No, I'm just kidding.
It definitely was Lymo.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
What's this?
Wait, no, this is the extraction room.
Arrow.
No, it's not.
There's nothing to extract.
I thought this was the one we extracted from.
Maybe not.
Look at this.
You can open these.
Oh!
Yeah.
Oh, there's a blood rose in there.
There's money.
Oh, money.
I'm sorry after you.
No, no, you can have it.
Try it.
I tried this.
I grabbed it.
Hold.
I still don't know.
what stashing does i don't know either maybe it shows up
after the day is over maybe it's so hard to see in this oh
gelatinous cube wow oh oh we have to pee on it oh oh he's oh
he's aggressive oh he's aggressive tempus i want to are you
gonna do it arrow he peep on him i don't think we know how i
don't know how yeah i'm pretty shy i just i can't go right
tornado i definitely couldn't go with so many people
watching yeah right oh well okay okay that's cool oh never
mind i mean your tornado sort of like you know wasn't me an
army you know so that's true should we find limo and extract
yeah yeah how do we extract i still don't know where to go
for that no i think we got it i think honestly i think the
goal is We should figure out where the extraction is,
because there's an entire chest that she'll live and we
won't.
She's over here.
Arrow.
There's something super valuable up here.
I want it.
It's golden, but I need to get to it.
Oh.
Arrow.
I'm waiting for my up dogs.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I got it.
Oh, what is it?
Yeah!
Up dog.
Where is it?
Oh, and a chest.
Oh.
How do you...
Are we okay?
That does not sound like a scream of victory.
Wait, what was that?
Lymo?
Wait, Lymo's dead!
Oh, no!
Wait, how did she die?
She just fell on me.
Wait, where's the gold?
It's so scary.
She said there was a gold thing up there.
She broke it.
It was like sick.
She said it in the chest and then she screamed.
Yeah.
Wait, look out, look out, look out!
What's that?
Shit, it's okay, it's okay.
It's still...
Five minutes left.
He doesn't...
It's a ceasefire.
I think it might have been a mimic.
Or something.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, here!
Oh, here!
It says warp to extraction.
This is the thing that...
That Lime would try before, though.
Will it work?
Yeah.
Oh, I don't know.
I was dead.
Wait, I don't know how you guys got up there.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, come on, come on, come on.
Wait, where's Lime was dead?
body oh um i dropped it on you guys oh look look at this oh
there's the ponder orb and then the extraction is right here
it's literally right here i guess we should look it now do
we have do we get do we need more money i mean we're doing a
good job we are freaking rich yeah yeah good job team Good
job, team.
Good job.
See, guys, we don't need Limu to win a game.
See, you know, those like charts where they're like- Where
do you think all the money came from?
Yeah, Limu is 99% of our group.
Look at that.
We lived though.
A 1% lived.
Arrow.
Hey.
Good try to push you out.
Oh, ow.
Arrow.
No!
Oh
We made it Nice So do you know what happened to me?
What happened?
I found I found a chest and I said oh a chest and and the
game went tempest Okay, and blew me out of the fucking
window with my own style Oh
What?
Did we do it?
Hey buddy Is this our patron?
Oh my god No, he's our boss.
Whoa, don't squish me.
Oh, this is freaky.
I'm tiny.
Arrow.
That's our boss.
No, he teaches us new spells.
Yeah, he's watching us.
New quota.
We made him $900, and he gave us 12 gold.
Basement key.
Ooh, a basement key.
What's the house for?
Is it this house?
That's a chat.
So if I start a thing before I die, Do I lose them?
Is the sound balance okay now?
I still have my...
Oh my god, he does look like the Katamari guy.
Does he?
Because I stashed a bunch of things, but I don't know if it
leaves if I die.
Oh, I opened the basement!
Oh, sweet.
Oh.
This is where we stashed your stuff?
Forbidden magic.
Oh, I think so.
Maybe.
Inventory pool.
Oh my god.
There's so much stuff in here!
Stop!
That's where we stashed!
Wait, I have...
I have the basilisk card here.
I'm gonna stash this then.
you can make stuff we can make potions yeah there's gold
here should we take this gold healing potion healthy oh oh i
don't know wait what we stash all of this i guess so so we
can make uh oh there's a flight potion i found your money on
the ground yeah can i play a wand i promised i won't blow
myself out the window again guys there's a frog potion we
can become frogs Thank you.
What do I, how do I get rid of this egg that's in my hand?
Uh, press F and then Q.
F?
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Let me stash it.
Yeah, stash it.
Oh wait, it showed up.
It showed up.
Oh, cool.
Okay.
We have 87 gold now.
We should treat ourselves to something.
Oh my god.
One of our quests is to burn things, so I think we should
all get torches.
Oh, that's true, that's true.
They're also, they're available for free in the castle
rooms.
Oh, that's true.
I stole this one from a, from a wall.
I know how to do this.
Oh.
Do I have a wand?
I have a wand.
Wait.
Yes.
Oh, it regroup even.
Up, dog.
Wait, now I can buy everything.
What if I get an astral wand?
What if I get?
A grotesque wand.
What if I get a fairy in a bottle?
What if I get...
I'm gonna get the grotesque.
Oh, sprout scales.
And flock oaklessly.
Do I have more?
Achoo.
Piss yuck.
One more, B.
What is this?
I bought a gross wand.
Wait, was it a stamina one?
It's lemonade, right?
Fish yuck.
Wait, will this turn you into a fish?
Can I try?
Yeah, yeah.
Fish yuck.
Oh my god.
Oh, who else is talking like that?
Why do you sound like that?
Uh-oh, I can't hear you anymore.
Well.
Oh.
Hello.
I can hear you.
I can hear.
Hola.
Biblioteca.
That was awesome.
That was so awesome to watch.
Wait, do you want to try?
What happened?
Here, hold on.
I got a new wand.
I got a wand.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Use it.
Wait.
hold on oh uh uh piss yuck ew what the heck oh my god how
did you get the pissing one you know that what they're you
know what you're giving them you know what you're giving
them right now you know what kind of art is gonna come from
this you but we do have a treat yourself clean yeah yeah
here someone else can try it someone else can try it Turn me
into a fish!
Turn me into...
Oh!
What is this?
Achoo!
Yeah, it's gross snot.
Ew!
You literally have like a... like a...
Fishyuck!
I'm a fish!
Whoa!
Go my steam!
Glove, glove, glove.
I'm fishing it up.
Whoa!
Thank you for hydrating me!
Wait, how do I get- I'm stuck!
Wait, I don't know where I'm going!
Help me!
I'm stuck!
Okay.
Hey, welcome back.
Thank you.
Well, you really, uh, really want.
Well, now we know how to pee on the, um, the, the, the
slime.
Yeah, now we can fill that contract.
That's true, that's true.
Explode slime with piss.
Who else wants the grotesque wand?
I don't know.
Hold on, let me look.
Try it.
Oh, blessed one.
Swap.
Oh, what's that?
Oh, it sounds cool down.
Dang.
Oh, wait.
Achoo.
Oh, where'd she go?
Where'd she go?
Oh, she didn't even teleport behind you.
Oh, no, she teleported.
Okay.
I just disappeared.
Don't worry.
This one is like teleporting and stuff, I guess.
Oh, hello, everybody.
I am fish.
Wait, yours doesn't get the voice for some reason.
She does.
She has the voice.
Are you saying don't you?
Oh, no, the voice might make you.
This is like Beyblade.
Yeah, let it rip.
I'm ripping it or I'm ripping it.
I'm the noble steed.
You are a beautiful noble, slightly stinky steed.
Yeah, we'll save up for the last wand.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we gotta get that one.
The blessed wand.
That's gonna be a heal wand, right?
I'll take the piss wand.
Yeah, okay, is anyone's... is Lymo sounding weird?
Weird or is that just my document?
Why did you automatically pee on me?
I didn't do it.
I didn't even know it was going.
Sorry.
I couldn't hold it in.
You didn't know this.
I just know you gotta go, you gotta go, you gotta go.
Do I sound weird, Doki?
Yeah, you sound like you're like doubled up.
Yeah, you sound normal to me.
I think there's some glitches with the fish.
Oh, yeah.
Earlier, Doki kind of sounded like that.
like she was in a box for me so i assume it like it's just a
reality i think maybe when we teleport we'll like fix itself
yeah oh yeah are you marking your territory with the piss is
that it i'm active maybe you look at it oh if i say ew then
it just starts shooting you're just ready to like double
attack someone are you good no that's not true your head was
like angled down and everything oh my god i'm studying does
everybody sound okay now chat We gotta piss on the slime.
We see it.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We see the slime.
Yeah.
That will be my duty.
Piss on it.
Yeah.
Make sure to drink enough water, mate.
Make sure you drink enough water.
Oh, yeah, I will.
Yeah.
Tempest.
Yeah, reload.
Oh, Tempest.
Is there a one that lets me ponder lots of fire?
Because I do like lots of fire.
Oh, yeah, we need the fire.
Oh, fuck, I hit my head.
I'm looking for a slime.
It's like when you get stung by jellyfish, you guys.
I see a problem now.
Oh, what's that?
I don't have anything to, like, knock stuff down.
You didn't keep your other ones?
Throw it with your hands.
Oh, no.
I have something called astral eyes.
It just lets me see things.
Whoa.
Oh.
What does that do?
Arrow.
I think all the ones are overrated.
I can see you all.
It's like I have wizard vision.
Wizard.
We don't want to go in there.
We don't want to go.
Why?
Turn him into a fish.
He's kind of cool with it, though.
Or piss on him.
Wait, turn him in.
Wait, see if he can turn him into a fish.
Turn him into a fish.
Fish, yuck.
Oh,
I don't think that worked.
Wait, wait.
Piss on him.
Piss, on him.
Piss, yuck.
Do you think he likes it?
Oh, he's mad.
I don't think he likes it.
He's mad.
I'm too busy.
Wait, don't, guys.
Oh, with my eyes.
It works!
It's the worst!
Kill him!
Arrow!
Fishyuck!
That was the worst possible thing.
Tempest!
Cried toward them.
Oh, it's like a big...
Tempest!
Oh my God.
Tempest is not working.
Oh, there you go.
Oh my God.
Why does it go towards me?
There's an eyeball!
There's an eyeball that shoots...
I'm okay, I'm okay.
It's not okay!
It doesn't...
Achoo!
Oh!
Tempest!
Oh, shoot.
Why did I do that?
I meant to do it in here.
Arrow.
Oh.
Are we even damaging him?
I don't think so.
That room is too scary.
I'll get out of there.
What the heck is this?
Oh.
Nice.
Kind of sick though.
Oh.
Piss yuck.
What if I fill them up?
I thought those were holes.
Oh, I'm getting them yellow.
Oh I'm actually getting them.
I'm actually...
They're actually turning yellow.
Oh.
I didn't mean to.
Wait.
Is anybody alive?
It's a thing tap piss.
Is anyone...
Is anyone alive?
Oh.
Where's Lymo?
I think Lymo is doing her job.
Okay.
But we're getting harassed by a man in armor.
Oh hey!
Arrow!
Wait, what's happening in here?
Everything okay, okay?
I've been burning things!
Oh!
Good job!
Hello!
Thank you.
Look, I got this for you.
Oh, thank you!
I will.
I'll drink it right now.
What the hell?
Tempest!
Wait, we gotta go.
Am I a frog?
Oh, there's the door!
Not yet!
Oh, there's a door!
Oh!
Wait, did I die?
Who's just trying to kill my human?
No!
I tried to become a frog.
Did she drop her wand?
Oh, I probably did.
I'm always a ghost in game.
That guy is tough.
There's a frog down there.
Oh no, no, no, no.
Lumen.
Oculus.
Animal.
Vita.
Corpus!
Is this me?
Atlas!
What is happening?
Blumen!
Oculus!
What is going on?
Anima!
What is happening?
Bit?
Oh my god!
I'll go get my stuff!
Wait, I don't have my stuff though.
Astral eyes.
No!
I'm doing this!
Oh!
Um, uh, uh, Snuffy brought me back!
Oh Yeah Don't pay any mind to what I've got in my hand No,
you can keep it You can have it It's kind of gross I stole
it That's okay Uh oh, wait I'm stuck Oh, I'm not Wait, oh I
just wanted to burn stuff there guys Yeah Guys, I'm getting
ca- Hepist!
Hepist!
Just loop him!
Where's the extraction?
How do you get- Hello?
Why is everything in this congregated into this room?
Why couldn't we let it here?
Is the guy doing that?
You good?
Ah!
No!
Oh my god, the eye is back, the eye is back.
Oh no, not the eye, not the eye!
Everything is
in...
What's up, me?
You can revive people in this room.
You can revive them.
Yeah, I noticed that.
You came back to life.
Yeah.
Oh.
It's okay, we stay here.
Wait!
Oh yeah, he can't come in here.
He can't come in here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's our savior.
Oh!
What the fuck?
I do live!
You live!
I didn't know!
I don't know!
Oh, don't look back.
Gluck, gluck, gluck.
Oh my god, the health potion only gives you 10 HP.
What is the point?
All right, I think we've got five in extraction.
Oh, there's a frog.
What's that?
Oh, yeah, the same frog I saw.
Oh, you came down here and you chose to go back up?
Like, why would you do that?
No, there was a mimic.
There was literally a mimic down here.
Oh.
Someone grab that.
Open.
Tempest.
Oh, see you got- Oh!
Five.
So, we might- I think someone's dead.
No!
May have- me perhaps.
I don't think so.
Tempest.
Arrow.
Shoot.
I don't think everyone survived.
Why is this area so hard?
We did too good of- Fish, yuck!
Good job!
Run past it.
Run past him.
Wait, but where do we run to?
Arrow.
Guys, this is a dead end.
Oh, shit.
No, no, no, there's a stairs.
There's stairs here.
Go, go, go, go, go.
We gotta move.
Where are we now?
Um, we just gotta look for the extraction room.
I found it!
Oh, I found the porcelain throne!
Guys, guys, come on!
Tempest.
Oh, oops.
Warp East?
Uh-oh, that's not the...
Hello?
Arrow.
Wait, where's my...
Oh!
Doki!
I can't hear you.
Wait, are you really Doki?
Arrow.
Are you really Doki?
Jump if you're Doki.
Okay.
What happened?
I can't hear you!
I think Nimmy died.
Are you telling me to follow?
Come on, boy.
Are you telling me to follow you?
Is that what you're telling me?
There's so much to destroy, though.
Uh.
Are you telling me to follow you?
Are you... are you... Come on, boy, jump if you're telling
me to follow you.
That wasn't a jump.
Little Timmy fell down the well?
What's this?
Oh.
Why are they doing?
Why are you clapping?
This is to warp east.
Ew!
What do you want me to use your words?
Okay.
Maybe it'll fix itself.
Oh, 75.
Nice.
Little Timmy fell down the well?
Azul?
What the game thinks I'm saying.
Ouch.
This way?
Oh, we're so...
Wait, this way.
We haven't gone this way.
Oh, shit.
Ziggy potion.
I heard something kind of nasty.
Oh, it must be up here.
Just go!
Go!
Activate it!
Most approaches.
Woo-woo!
He's not gonna catch me.
Oh my god.
Good!
It's like, where is little Timmy?
I couldn't hear you.
That was pretty good though.
All things considered, except I think we lost our wands.
We gotta keep our money.
We didn't lose all our money.
We did it.
I got your wand, but I couldn't get to the extraction.
I'm sorry.
I couldn't get your wand.
Wait, there's new wands now.
I was catching Doki and she hadn't meant to quit.
talk to each other and when i when you resurrected me and
mimi i couldn't hear you at all oh no that seems to happen a
lot in these games yeah i was trying to tell you i had your
wand oh okay i literally ran away like my i thought it was
like a mimic i thought it was like one of those they
impersonate the other character i was just like i was like
trying to communicate i was like yes yes did you see the
fucking skull spider up close it was the most horrifying
thing spider oh my god oh my god i don't know the thing that
you were running from it was a skull spider the thing that
came up the stairs it was horrifying oh not this what is
that oh god it's a friend oh frog oh he looks like a frog
look at him he's our little oh he pukes money what the phone
oh my gosh he just he just like threw up a gold coin oh my
god follow me i abducted him from this family us that's cool
i wanted to see what the grim war was i'm gonna i'm gonna
just quickly go and look and see if there's another torch
downstairs dog dog dog she's
moonwalking she's moonwalking oh my god oh yeah making those
moves good job lymo oh oh lymo disconnected oh my out you're
the killer yeah you're gonna kill people yeah that'll be
huge yeah up dog can I pick up the stuff in the basement and
sell it dog dog dog nice dog if you say up dog and then you
keep saying dog you stay up longer oh really up dog dog dog
dog dog dog dog oh my god you're ready all
right we just got wait is lime back oh lime's back she's
yellow now oh you're yellow oh you scared me yellow i want
to be yellow you came from the forest it scared me wait
she's not talking on my screen yeah you're not i mean either
yeah you're not talking at all lime Like even if you're
talking, oh, there it is.
I hear you, hear you, hear you.
At least at my settings.
Oh, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I mean, I said hello.
Did you say her the hell out of you?
Is she dead?
She's gonna be.
Okay.
The first thing you do is burn me alive when I'm dead.
I see who it is.
I see Ignaz Tong.
Oh my god!
Whoa, that's crazy.
Yay, adventure!
I thought I heard Snuffy downstairs, but she was not, that's
weird.
Oh, no, Snuffy is over here.
Wait, does that mean you can take stuff that we stashed?
Oh, she's using the portal to do it, I see.
Oh!
She truly is a wizard.
Wait, we can get the... the arcana.
Yeah, get the... that one, get that one.
We could get a... we could get a... we could get a... a
wand, yeah.
I didn't have to end his life.
Wait, but like, what happened to her?
What happened to her?
I sold her for zero dollars.
She was worthless, I'm sorry.
Oh!
Oh my god!
He was losing money!
What?
There's another one!
There's another one over here!
Wait, let's see how much my potion costs.
Oh, I can sell it for five gold!
Thank you!
Oh, wait, it's already gone.
Oh, yeah, Snuffy already linked it.
Oh, oops.
Betrayer.
I have a bat.
Oh, wait, you did.
Oh, so you get a bat and we all lose a frog.
I see.
Teleportana.
Wait, what?
Whoa.
What is this bad?
I'm happy with my standard wand and just some source of
fire.
I sold mine.
Thank you for nothing.
I want to try the zippy.
Up dog.
Dog, dog, dog, dog.
I'm down.
Disaster passive income.
What's the point?
We'll get another one.
I also did that.
Look for fire.
Looking for fire.
Hymn is done.
Come on, you got that.
That last guy.
Arrow.
What is this?
A goblin tooth.
Tempest.
What do we do with this orb?
What is whistling?
What was that?
Oh.
Not doing anything.
Wait, Nimi, are you talking?
Up dog.
Oh no.
Okay.
Arrow.
Oh my god, that's the best ever.
Head dog.
Yeah!
What's that?
Era.
In this tongue.
Arrow.
Sona.
Oh, that spell doesn't do damage on items.
Oh, it doesn't.
Aerial.
Yeah, the kind one doesn't.
Oh, oh, yeah, it's there.
I'm just breaking some dice.
Tempest.
Aerial!
Oh, you're dying!
Aerial.
Arrow.
Tempest.
Oh.
Just grab it.
Kill him!
Arrow.
Ten gold!
Wait, there was ten gold!
Ouch!
I'm trying to get the gold, hold on!
We need to get fired.
I thought where's the gold?
I can see it!
Oh, there it is!
Okay, I got it.
Shit.
He's coming.
Run.
Oh, wait.
I want to drop that.
I hear another.
He's aggroed on me.
Oh, no!
Era.
I'm a wizard and wizard that I've been withed.
I'm hiding.
Why is he gone?
I don't think I'm actually playing here.
Can he hear me?
Hello?
I don't think anything's happening.
This guy spawn camping me?
All right, follow me.
Uh, big guy coming.
Big guy in the house.
Big guy pants okay.
Yeah, he's like aggroed on me.
I can't leave.
Uh, he aggroed to me for a little bit.
I don't know where he went after that.
Yeah, he's downstairs.
There's at the bottom.
Where is Doki to use her spells on this guy?
Good job.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
I'm leaving.
Behind you, Doki.
Run!
Come on!
This way!
Oh wait, I still can't find a fucking torch.
Oh, yeah.
I just want to set things on fire.
She wants to set the world.
Oh, what is that?
What is that?
Ah!
What the fuck?
I don't know.
Run, run, run, run.
Just run, just run.
Come up, come up, come up, up, up, up.
Okay, no, that's the comment, it's the comment, it's the
comment.
Oh, Christ.
There's too many things.
Everything is here.
I just want to break stuff.
Holy crap, what was that?
Did you see that other thing?
The guy that jumps?
Yeah.
What the hell?
Oh god, I hate the big guy.
Oh my god, there's two things in here.
Holy shit.
Arrow.
I feel very defenseless.
Me too.
Sorry.
That's okay.
There are places to hide, but it's tough.
It is.
to get to the exit yeah there's a big sword guy but i think
if you crouch there's two yeah there's two of them oh you
can crouch yeah yeah control the crouch yeah there's all my
flame there we just sneak past and get to the exit i thought
doki was supposed to kill these guys for us doki doki got
hit in the back by the big guy and i don't know if she
survived because that was like the third time i saw it
happen oh fuck Oh!
Oh
my god!
Nobody is lit.
What?
What happened to the fire?
Look!
These guys are invincible.
Why was I supposed to know he was gonna be behind me?
I was supposed to know that.
Oh my god.
I can only use fire magic in front of me, not behind me.
Someone didn't cover my back.
Someone didn't have my back there.
I didn't have the fire weapon.
Oh my god.
There's two of them for real.
Wait, it's just it's Snuffy and I believe in oh my god
Snuffy and Lymo.
They both 13 HP.
I didn't even care about it.
There's a third guy.
Yeah, upstairs where Snuffy is.
Oh my god.
Lymo has a hundred HP and Snuffy has 13.
I did not look too good for her.
Oh, okay.
game actually i know right it's literally a repo but like
but worse oh my god oh no there's another one yeah it's like
metal gear solid it is yeah this is just like metal gear oh
my god please oh my god snuffy snuffy oh my god those jokes
the jokes oh the goblin oh my god there's one on each floor
Wait, you should go to the castle.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Teleportana.
No!
No, no, no, no!
Give me one level, please give me one level.
I don't deserve to be a wizard.
No!
We're gonna lose so much of money because none of us are in
the extraction.
Oh my god.
We have a lot of money.
We do have a lot of money.
That's so true.
Yeah, yeah, we do have one more night.
One more night.
We can just make it up for it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stop peek at your ass off these fucking stairs.
There's no point in...
Why do we bring her body?
It's not like...
Maybe I keep my items.
oh you poor cool oh my god i hope she has my wand i don't
know if you drop it when you die i know she's holding two
win ones guys no take it take it take it take it take it oh
oh that's okay we 400 we just need 400 gold we're good right
we're good yeah one more day i kept your free Snuffy, I
couldn't figure out how to grab your little friend,
unfortunately.
I was like...
Oh, he's still here!
He's still alive!
I don't know why he's here.
I don't have the wand anymore, but...
Oh, no!
Take it, take it, take it!
There's a telekinesis.
Why did you keep...
Why did you keep the wind wands?
You know we get free wands here, right?
I just picked it up because there was something on the
floor.
Oh, there was nothing else.
She was really on survivalist.
Doki, I got you this.
I got you this because Snuffy killed yours.
My new frog!
Oh!
Yeah, I want to try the wand of illusions.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe you could turn into a frog.
Alright, here we go.
Float Oculus.
Whoa!
Oh my god, I'm all the way over here!
Oh, is it like a...
I'm like, I'm like, I'm having an out-of-body experience.
It's like your drone.
Yeah, I'm a drone.
I'm a drone.
Wait, how do I go?
How do I stop this?
Go back in.
Go back in my body.
Oh, I'm back.
Oh, it's time.
It's time.
Okay, okay.
Let's see.
We got...
Poof me.
Oh!
Don't break me!
Do you think one of these will aggro you if you disguise
yourself as a chair?
Don't sit on me.
Arrow.
We have...
I'm still planning to play musical chairs.
Hello?
Wait, what happened?
Oh, there's so many of me!
What am I doing?
He's dancing.
You're the deceptive one now.
And then there's Shrink Ana.
Why you get out from under my cloak?
It changes everyone's voices.
Those are all of them.
Oh, sorry.
It changes all of them for me, the voices.
But that's very cool.
All right.
Wait, where's Limeo?
Right here.
Hey, are we all ready?
Yeah.
I'm ready.
All right.
Let's go.
I'm extracting.
Oh, wait.
We're shuffie.
I swear to God.
She sells our frog again.
I swear to God, Stuffy, you sell our passive income again.
I'm gonna earn some income with my new music career.
Final night.
Guys, let's lock in.
Wizards.
Let's lock in.
Okay.
I just lost 5 XP.
Who did that?
Was that me?
What's that mean?
Arrow.
I'm heading.
I'm serious.
Might as well suck, man.
We have fun.
Looking for a torch.
Surely the game wouldn't cook me again.
Here we go.
Up the stairs.
Here we- Oh.
Eyeball, guys.
Shrinkana.
A little smaller.
Oh, wait, he's gone.
Oh, okay, cool.
He was so embarrassed by his small size.
He left.
It was above average.
I
messed up size shaming that poor eye.
Oh.
Oh, he's back.
He's back.
Keep size shaming him.
No, I don't think I will.
Wait, who's down here?
Yeah.
Tempest.
Go down.
Wait, where am I?
I gotta figure out where to go.
Yeah, I can't find like a door.
Are you freaking drunk?
Hello?
I can like bomb the windows.
Hi.
I go down.
I don't know.
Where the heck am I?
Where are the doors?
I can't tell where to go.
Oh no, it's so dark.
I have no light source.
Yeah, there's like nothing here.
Oh my god.
I tried to go down, but I can't see shit.
Are there stairs here?
Or am I crazy?
There's no stairs.
It's just over here.
No.
There's stuff over here.
The stairs here just goes back to the upstairs.
Oh, we have this area.
I didn't even say anything!
Oh.
Arrow.
Oh, okay.
Wait, that frog looks expensive.
Oh, shit!
Uh, uh, uh...
Flow talking...
No.
Dang it!
Well, he went the other way.
I can go up these stairs, maybe.
Shrink Ana.
Oh!
You don't see your ping either.
There's no ping.
No, no, no.
I haven't experienced a program that.
Hello.
What happened?
There's a guy downstairs.
Oh!
Wait, there's a frog!
Don't you dare.
It's a disco.
Guys, I'm desperate.
Arrow.
I'm scared.
Okay, downstairs safe.
Uh, he's going back downstairs!
There's two downstairs!
Maybe?
Shrinkana.
And then if I can grab it...
Yes!
I think we have to go upstairs, I'm pretty sure.
There's like nothing up here.
The second?
The third?
Trincona!
Poof me.
Okay, a chair's not gonna help you.
I thought that was the one that makes multiple of me.
I don't think the chair...
Uh, oh, it's on- Alright, I juke them.
I juke them again.
I can't keep jukeing this!
I gotta get this though, I gotta get this!
It's so expensive!
Drink Ana.
Oh shit.
Echo me!
Ow!
Did I make it?
I don't know.
Jukeed?
But not really.
me.
I don't know where I am.
Hello?
Is there anybody?
Is this a door?
Do I go down?
Hello?
It's definitely been taken care of.
Wait, is this where we started?
Wait, did I go back?
Hola.
The cave?
I think that's where we started.
Oh, shoot.
I'm so lost.
Everybody's gone.
Okay.
Oh, hi.
Oh, there you are.
Okay, have we gone up yet?
I don't know.
I'm so- Oh, do not go up!
Shrink it!
Where is it?
It's gone.
No, no, it's right here.
It's right here.
Where?
I think up is extraction.
You have to shrink it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Shrinkana!
Oh, it didn't work.
It didn't work.
I don't think that worked.
I don't think it didn't work.
It didn't work.
Watch this.
Oh my god.
Yeah?
Oh, we're coming.
We're coming.
Okay, please come.
Please come.
I really got...
I died.
No!
Wait!
Perfect!
Okay, wait, perfect.
Wait, no!
Snuffy, grab my wand, please!
It's right there!
That's not true.
I wouldn't...
No!
Snuffy!
Wait.
She can bring me back.
I can't.
her though.
I can watch it this time.
I wish I could hear her though.
Look at my body is floating.
She's playing the drums while she does it.
So funny.
Thank you!
But I can't hear you though, Snuffy.
I can't hear you.
Yeah.
My wand is over here!
Unless someone grabbed it.
No.
Okay, good.
Wait, is the other one?
My basic wand?
My basic wand is...
Oh, here.
Nice.
Okay.
I'll follow you.
Oops.
I don't know why it does that.
Sorry.
It's like a...
What's this one do?
Warp East.
I think... Let's try it, yeah.
Unless we're by the spider.
Wait.
No.
I'm coming.
I think that was a mimic.
Oh!
Oh, we made it!
What is this?
Mimi's doing...
She's doing a...
She's doing a vocal quiz right now.
I don't hear anything.
She's just locked in.
Oh, I hear...
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Where are you?
Oh, dang.
I'm below you.
Oh, you were so close.
Oh, eyeball.
Trigata.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Run.
Oh.
She still attacks.
I just like to make him small.
Oh, hi.
Hello.
Oh, shit.
Um, there's so...
I thought it was Nimi up there.
What happened to Nimi?
Nimi is there.
She's doing the time.
Yeah, she was there.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, she's still stuck in the fucking place.
She's still doing it.
It's okay.
We still have a minute.
We have to wait on the exit, I think.
Otherwise, we're all getting out or getting lost.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If she doesn't show up in a minute, we peace out.
Right, right, right.
Stuffy is helping her right now.
Is there anything else around?
I mean, we can watch it here.
Oh, yeah.
We can watch them, yeah.
Ooh, ponder the hole.
Look at her going.
Stuffy is watching.
Yeah, Sophie is watching.
She's just standing there.
If she's watching, and then...
Ooh.
Oh.
I don't think they...
Did she get out?
That seems like it.
I think that's what happens.
I think she can at least leave between attempts maybe.
No?
Yes?
Oh.
Oh yeah, she's going.
She's coming.
They're coming.
They're booking it.
All right, the moment we see the...
Come here!
Hurry!
Up here!
We're up here!
Uh-oh.
I think I have to press it.
Shrink on a...
Did I shrink you on accident?
Two, one!
Oops, I think I shrunk you guys.
We're here!
Wee!
Run!
Wait, wait, one, two, three, four!
Wait, there's four of us!
Where's the fifth?
Oh, oh, there she is!
Oh!
Yeah, we...
I think I accidentally shrunk them.
Yeah, I was like, wait, there's four of us, and I see a tie,
so he's just jumping across.
Oh, my God!
We actually made it!
Big money!
Yeah, big money.
Are you so happy?
We are happy.
Papa Moon, we did it!
We brought you so much!
We brought you so much money!
Have we pleased you?
generosity here i'll give you a little dance whoof me whoa
what am i what am i what are you i don't know
21 gold wow that's it where am i oh i'm in the ceiling or
the sky i mean oh where am i oh yeah wait where am i am i
i'm falling i think i just as well i think i just fell
through the earth I don't know.
I think so.
I'm afraid if we...
Have you tried moving forward?
Are we gonna fall to our death?
No, I'm so scared!
I can see the light.
I can see the light from below us.
Oh my god.
I see the moon.
It's so beautiful.
Wow.
Oh my god.
I see the moon.
It's so beautiful.
Wow.
Well, let me...
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna jump.
Oh no.
Ah!
Oh my god, wait, where is everybody?
Oh, they're over here.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, good.
Guys, you won't understand what we just went through.
I couldn't even explain it to you.
No, I watched.
I was there, and I watched, no, like, did you figure out
eventually how to make it move?
Make what?
Or the thing.
Did you figure out how to make the thing move?
What's the thing?
It was pitch?
It's pitch, but it's confusing, I think.
Oh, no.
It was, yeah, it was like putting the ball in the middle of
the hole.
but it looked really contrived.
We didn't sell some more stuff, and we should be able to
afford the fire wand.
We're selling some more stuff.
Oh, yeah!
I would love the fire wand.
Do you guys like this wand, or I can sell it too?
I don't...
It's good, but...
What is that?
Well, you should keep your special wand.
This is the...
Yeah, you should keep it.
The special, like, the floating wand.
I just realized your hat lights up when you speak.
That's cute.
Oh, it does!
You're right!
That's so cute!
It's so cute.
Oh, wait, we might...
We need to get the containers because...
you get 250 chaos dude i want to buy the blessed wand okay
mine has like been the same contracts this whole time yeah
no i have a different contract i have break things with
arcane me too me too i think ours is bugged can i buy the
blessed wand i'll sell my wand so that somebody else can
have wait how much is the blessed one i haven't had a wand
yet 50.
yippee 50 we don't well we do not have enough it's okay
Yeah, I'm sorry.
You can run and burn!
You can!
Oh, I'm fast!
Ooh, that's cool.
Whoa!
Wait, did you guys sell stuff already?
No.
I sold, I sold, we sold for the fire wand.
Oh, I can sell this real quick.
I can sell my wand if you guys want a different wand.
I can sell the clothes on my...
I can sell the clothes on my bag!
whatever we want to have a wand.
Ignis, boom.
What is, is it like mine?
Oh, yeah, it is a mine.
Whoa.
That seems strong.
Yeah.
The thing is, Tom, I really control where, oh yeah, get to
talk with you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Grab, ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are those sword guys really invincible?
I don't think so.
You can, like, you can see them with the wind at least.
Yeah, yeah.
Do we have a...
What kind of arcane magic?
Dog.
I think it's only three dogs.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, we can only have three dogs per person.
Up dog.
I'm distracting, but then I'm also going to go home.
Dog.
Nothing bad will happen to you.
Oh.
Oh, I should have looked at the Grimoire for my custom wand.
You're right.
i'm so curious what like high bastion the the little like
puzzles will reward you with if we could actually do that
better be good yeah right i hope it's like a wand arrow yeah
sorry sorry to be arrow okay don't think you're just using
the bathroom arrow i deserve that oh no i didn't
That's great.
I like that.
I like killing
the little babies.
I heard something.
All right.
I'm back.
Welcome back.
It's time.
Find a clock into my nine to five.
Ignis tongue.
Yeah, there is fall damage.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ouch!
Oh my gosh!
Stop!
Your sticks and stones may break my bones, but Lyamu's words
will hurt me.
No, I always do the earth fall down.
Whoa, look at this.
I'm on the ceiling.
It's the rooftop.
Is there anything here?
Ignis Tongue.
No, there usually isn't.
Oh, I see the extraction room.
Ariel.
What's wrong with you?
Shrink Anna.
I can't understand what you're saying.
That way they were me, right?
That way they made me speak.
That's what she sounds like.
You know, like those little monkeys had to be cranked in the
little music box.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're the monkey, Dutch.
I think this is where we came from.
I think so, too.
Yeah, I think so.
Wait, actually, I'm lost.
We don't, we haven't went through this door.
Yes, that's where we came from.
That's where we started.
Yeah, that's where we started.
This way is a new way.
This over here is new.
Okay, thank you.
That one knows where to go.
Yeah.
That one.
Yeah, Limeo!
Make us money!
Oh, there's a goblin.
We're gonna get evicted.
There's some stuff going on.
What the fuck is going on over there?
What is that?
Oh, that's the eyeball!
Oh, that's an eyeball!
That's an eyeball!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh!
There we go.
Bobbom.
You're welcome, guys.
I earned the $12 today.
And I got us a glowing mushroom from it.
I don't know what counts as our king, man.
So I haven't been able to do complete one of the contracts,
which is annoying.
Oh Yeah, Ignor's tongue I think this is the revive room
Aero, oh wait, this is the This is the revive room.
Yeah, Aero.
Yeah, yeah.
So we have to go there Yeah
Aero Aero Every dollar counts apparently you can't yo you
can kill the sword guys oh you can nice that's what someone
in my chat said I trust your chat they wouldn't lie they
wouldn't oh where'd they go oh watch out for the eyeball
is it still there we should follow them once the eye's gone
he's gone he's gone you good?
yep cool
hello Hello?
Are they here?
Oh, the eyeball is here now.
What the heck?
Oh, good.
I don't even know what he does.
Does he just zap your HP or?
I guess so.
Oh, he's gone.
I don't know if I've lost track.
Oh, no.
Where are you guys?
Arrow.
There's a self-warf over here too.
Yeah, we're up here.
Whoa, I went the other way.
Oh.
There's, okay.
there's another mini game over here if you guys want to try
but there were like a ton of rage there like the big spider
oh no we have we have uh our fire mage yeah let's try scale
based we had to do the scale arrow he's got yaf more arrow
yab yab yab yab yab
do you think willow amber burn i like just throwing
everything number one frog fan wait there's a thing here a
gem oh it came out of the chest yeah oh there's something
else too there's some coal coal the gem won't let me stash
it i wonder what it is uh you have to like hold it with you
i guess the whole time because i died with one on the other
day oh wait there's a Oh, there's stairs here.
I don't even see where you went.
So dark.
I've got leftover pizza after the stream.
I'm excited.
Woo-hoo!
What kind?
I'm gonna eat all the pizza.
I got... It's got, like, ham and pineapple and corn.
Oh, what?
That sounds awesome!
It's really tasty!
Oh, the ice here!
The ice here!
Ah, ah, ah, oh!
My music's pretty.
Yeah, arrow.
Okay, if we got...
What are you guys doing in here?
What is this?
It's a test of smogs.
The fuck?
I don't think it liked whatever you guys did.
Hello?
Are they okay?
Okay, no, you're good.
Spawning in and it's staring.
Are they okay?
Yeah, they're all good.
Oh, okay.
I can't hear anybody.
Errol.
I have an eyeball from the melee on my street.
And then we're like, get it out.
Two eyeballs.
I have two eyeballs.
Two eyeballs just chilling.
No, okay, those are dead.
Oh, yeah, there's two eyeballs.
They only hurt when...
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think it's almost there.
If you're stamina, is that...
Oh,
we did it.
We did it!
Yeah!
Go in.
Whoa!
A bunch of wands!
Oh, they were won!
Yay!
I don't want me.
The mimic of you is just on the stairs here.
Ah!
You guys all good over here?
Nope.
We did, we did, it really gave us bronze.
Dude, I'm so happy.
Look, Sana.
Oh, oh!
Ignite Tongue!
Ah!
Please, please, I learned it!
Ignite Tongue!
Ah!
Get out!
What is that?
It's a mimic!
It's pretending to be snuffy.
Oh, it is?
I don't appreciate that.
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't know it could mimic people.
I have a revive potion if anybody dies.
And it just screams when it pulses damage.
Is there no way on the other side of that room?
Up there, that's the extraction point over there.
You gotta go over there.
Oh.
That big tower.
Oh, we get to it, I think.
Up here, up here.
Where did Doki go?
I don't know.
I think she ran the other way.
Oh, God.
Oh.
Oh, here it is.
It's just right here.
Oh, yeah, we're good.
We're good.
Oh, cool.
We should, uh, the mimic's still here.
Oh, no.
It's, it's evil me.
It's evil me.
Oh my God.
Stay away.
Fish.
Ignis Boom.
I've got a mine down.
Miss.
Ah!
Oh, I've been silenced.
Ignis, boom.
Snuffy talk.
Okay, we'll hit the mine and we'll be okay.
Okay.
We still have time.
Should we wait for them?
We could see.
Let's see if they're alive.
Let's see.
Let's see where they are.
Let's ponder them.
They're Stokie.
Oh, and they're Nimi.
They're alive, yeah.
We wait, we wait.
Real snuffy?
Real snuffy.
I'm real.
I don't know how to prove myself other than my talking is
bad.
Talking is being an easy way.
We're pondering.
It's so funny when you look around once you're pondering.
your arms are all up i like what's channeling our ether so
we can manifest the visions of all that i always had i'll go
see it i wonder if we should like go they're like at the
beginning yeah i think doki might have got lost two minutes
to get all the way over here no problem yeah does anybody
want to be heroic and lead them here i don't think when i
said two minutes a little bit over here no problem i mean it
is impossible for them to get to here in time yeah are they
i'm sorry let me clarify are they really at the beginning or
i saw the third floor which i think was at the beginning oh
no i do have two fancy ones so you definitely i think we all
have a fancy one we can't we can't i was gonna drop it i was
gonna drop them and leave yeah it's the mimic that worries
me true because my health is at 19 i don't think i'll make
it Here, wait, here, here, mint.
There's a health, I have a health potion.
No, it's okay because- We should probably save it and
extract.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But what if something, like, shows up right here and starts
killing us all and she takes one blow and dies?
I think it's a safe room.
I don't feel like they can't get into this room.
Yeah, I think it's a safe room.
Yeah, I've never seen anything in here.
Didn't we run away from a sword guy at the last hour?
Not up here, right?
I trust you, I trust you.
Luxana.
Yeah, we are not getting back to them in 55 seconds.
Oh my god, did they find another trap room?
No, they're teleporting.
They're teleport- Oh, they're so far away.
Ooh, I see a teleporter.
Yeah, I don't even know where they are.
No, we teleported, but it was quite long time ago, I'm
pretty sure.
And then...
If they find the...
What's it called, room?
The...
This puzzle room, then they can get here.
30 seconds.
They definitely got this, man.
Wait.
Where the fuck are they?
Flow to Oculus.
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
I don't think the other girls have boundaries.
Oh, oh, you guys!
Come on, come on, come on, come on!
Come on, come on!
Hurry up, yeah!
Oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, my body!
My body is dying!
What?
Oh,
fuck.
What happened?
She was outside the circle.
That was outside the circle!
No way!
I lost those wands!
Wait, did you crash too?
No, Mint was using a spell and couldn't move on to the
extraction point.
I couldn't move!
No, but you guys should have pushed me in!
You should have pushed me in!
I didn't see, I didn't know what you were doing!
I'm sorry!
I knew... I saw her outside of the circle.
stereo no I literally I crashed like Mint's used her spell
and then it just instantly crashed my game but I guess I
kept all my items oh here you go Mint why didn't you use
your spell in the circle why Mint have this wand I don't
like it as much I just want my torsion are you sure it's not
a great one it's not an actual great one I will have to say
I can probably I can do one more.
Agnes Tongue.
Oh, how do I...
What are you trying to do?
What was that?
What?
I gotta watch this.
Look at this.
Okay, go on third person.
Go on third person.
Oh, wait, what's third person again?
Oh, M.
Okay.
Grab on.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Oh, my God!
Oh, shit!
I have a portana.
Grab on.
Luxana.
What is Luxana?
I miss out on my little bitty.
The flames are going to be.
Tell the portana.
Whoa.
We have so many frogs.
Oh, don't forget to pick up the gold that they leave, you
guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Money, money, free money.
Money, money.
Must be funny.
Wait, do I have to pick it up?
Wait, I don't think I do.
How do I, like, chuck people away?
I chucked her away one time.
Grabana.
Drop.
I saw, like, the first time I used it, I chucked someone
away.
I freaking have the worst aim.
Grabana.
Wait, that's the one I have!
Me too.
That means we can grab someone closer to us.
Alright, are you guys ready?
Yeah!
Ready, ready, ready!
Whoa!
Grab on him!
You had the splints!
I'm so obsessed!
I forgot the Grimoire again!
Oh, we're at a haunted monolith.
Wait, that's new.
Is this where we were yesterday?
Errol.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, what is it?
Tempest.
Ouch.
Oh, I can grab onto items.
That's cool.
Oh, that sounds pretty handy.
You just, like, telephrag me?
I don't even know where I teleported.
Tempest.
There's so much cool items up here now.
Ignus Tongue.
Oh my god.
It's so dangerous.
It's fun, isn't it?
Yeah, it is pretty fun.
Are you sure you didn't want it?
Eventually you could have get...
Yeah, no, no, I'm good.
I'm good.
I'm really really tired.
So I don't want to sing it Oh, okay.
That's understandable.
Oh, Lyman.
We could make this LG if you want to hear more of your
beautiful voice As you like yell at objects.
I will.
I'll yell We're moving to the next.
Nimi!
Nimi Nimi!
Pick this tongue.
There's a slime here!
Does anyone have a group task?
No.
There's so many big balls.
Temp?
No!
Making so much money.
I can't say anything.
Rich.
Rich and knowledge.
and spells oh do you hear something there's a slime we don't
have the wait did anyone buy the gross test the gross test
squad because we're supposed to pee on it no oh no peeing on
the slime i guess not this time i got something expensive
tempus area oh guys you can't you can't push the slime where
is the slime he's up here with me Okay.
Hello.
I found the creepy guy in the dungeon again.
Have you seen him?
No.
Yeah, there was a creepy, you want to see the creepy guy in
the dungeon?
Yeah?
Yeah.
Let me break this while we go over there.
Shatter.
We drop it down here.
Oh!
Wait, so I just go down?
Nice.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I didn't even know there was a dungeon.
In here?
Oh my god, alien!
I don't know why he's here.
chills and then leaves again and then if you like leave and
come back he shows up again that's pretty neat yeah this
game has some fun stuff um guys um i saw mimi get abducted
by a dragon and then i ran away wait what um so uh the last
words i heard was there's a dragon
Oh my god, that was a one shot.
That was a one shot.
Wait, Nimmy's still alive.
Min-Min's are not okay.
How do I use the revive on here?
Oh.
Like.
Ouch.
Oh, she lived.
My feet.
She lived.
There was the dragon on there.
Oh, the Joker guy is too scary.
Hello?
I'm alive.
Yay, welcome back!
Mimi made it!
Up dog.
I think I've died every single game, you guys.
I think I've died literally every single game.
Jessica?
Yeah, there's a...
And also, it's...
The Jester is down here.
Okay, yeah, so the Jester is...
He looked at men and then he died.
It's because I'm so used to being dead, you know what I
mean?
There's a gigantic slime cube.
Oh, what the fuck is that?
What the fuck is that?
Yeah, the slime cube.
Oh, you found the guy in the basement?
Yeah, we found the guy in the basement.
The guy in the basement.
Oh my gosh.
The Jester's here.
Hey.
Oh, right behind you or right in front of us?
Oh, I gave him my potion.
And there's also a giant slime cube.
They shut the door on him.
Oh, I'm not sure what was going on with that.
Yeah.
He, you could trade with him.
Oh, thanks.
You eat your potion?
He gave me amber.
Amber?
I thought forward was where we came from.
Whoa, cool.
I'm lost.
I already, I'm already messed up.
Guys, I got like a smoothie.
This is the new area.
With ginger in it.
Trying to, I'm trying to, to adjust more to ginger i don't
like it oh teleport time and i know ginger is so you know oh
this is to nothing i think or maybe i'm a ghost but i still
try to take care of myself okay okay okay buddy okay wait
what's over there the extraction tower is over there oh boy
What if I, like, work onto this, like...
Oh!
What happened?
Air.
I said Gravana, and then I said didn't grab him, and then I
got grabbed.
Yeah, sometimes the spells don't work in our favor.
Did Doki die?
Oh, Doki fucking died the clown got her.
Oh!
Was it Snuffy Mimic?
Limeo, are you alive?
I thought you got abducted.
Oh, he knew you thought you got abducted!
Because things just don't...
Okay, the fact that the gesture is a one shot is pretty
fucked up.
I know!
I've been messed up.
You were like our test subject, too.
You were like, we're like, oh, wonder what happens if you
can't grab.
I got grabbed.
That's what happened.
It was fun.
It was a good time.
I think maybe I wasted money on that shitty-ass grab-bana
one.
You were only grabbing us and grabbing nothing else.
Oh.
Snuffy.
Oh, she gamed.
Where did Snuffy go?
Was she by herself?
Yeah, she's by herself.
She's getting...
You're moving all the furniture and stuff.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, the jukes of the century.
Oh, she's gaming.
She doesn't know they can open doors.
Oh, she made it back with them.
Oh, that's...
Wait, that's not Nimi, is it?
That's... that's not...
That's Nimi.
That's not Nimi.
She's like, Nimi!
Why are you looking at it?
I don't think she could...
she just like put her in the door and left she just as long
as i don't look at you i'll be okay why didn't why didn't
snuffy go in that area i wonder
i don't even know where she is and then where the rest of
the crew is yeah this map is huge oh lime was also getting
stopped supposed to be a monolith or some too i don't see
where it is oh why did i lose it didn't go the wrong way i
think i literally went the wrong way or something like i
wish there was like a a world map so we can see where
everyone yeah something like that oh my god you're real and
alive oh my god you're also real and alive oh my god wait
nimi has one hp one hp one hp in a dream what is limo i'm
scared are you above us extraction point is it's it's at the
end of this corridor Oh, oh, who the hell is that running
by?
Am I above you?
If you're with Nimi, Nimi knows the way back to it.
Oh, did she just say dead?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, you know, Snuffy was not the one I
expected to have died there.
What happened?
Uh, the clown bought me.
Oh, no.
Oh, you got grabbed.
Yeah, I didn't know what he did.
we're the grab crew dude this game is just sitting in the
corner yeah this game it has like well I think it's like
we're at like third stage now the difficulty spike is crazy
though they probably expect you to use like the the potions
and stuff we're just raw dogging it yeah we're just raw yeah
we're like we just sell all our ingredients for more wands
we're like we just want more wands we just want more wands
oh my god the clown no now
we're gonna watch one hp nimi yeah one hp nimi she's like i
believe in her i believe in her too someone's gonna sneeze
on her and then it's gonna be like oh look Oh no!
We got freaking cloud guns.
Oh my gosh, that was crazy.
That was crazy.
He turned right around and followed me.
Oh.
We did get a hundred, we got 163 though.
We have one more night, guys.
Yep.
I can do the one more night, but I gotta stop off your life.
Yeah, LG, LG.
Yeah, I want to know if we make it.
Also, if we don't make it, we can see what the death
animation is like.
Everybody grab your new wand.
It must be interesting.
LG, LG.
Woohoo!
Wait, I'm gonna see if we can get the grotesque one so we
can pee on this vibe.
Yeah.
Okay.
How much is it?
25?
Just sell everything.
He just kind of sprints towards you and one shots you.
It's fun.
I know.
This level is crazy.
It's tough.
I'm selling stuff.
The bard.
I'm not a grotesque one.
She's so cool.
Need more.
The frog.
Did he drop any cash?
Hey frog.
Give me your lunch money.
Give me your lunch money frog.
I didn't mean to do that.
Oh!
He gave us an extra...
Grab the frogs.
They'll give you more money.
Oh, they like it.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
We got it, we got it, we got it, we got it.
We got pissed yuck again.
Ew.
I'm tipping the musician.
Hot cross buns!
Oh, it is!
Oh!
Wait.
Dancing.
Mary had a little lamb.
Yeah!
Little lamb.
They're taller now
than me, sweet slice wide as snow.
Storm tower beneath the mountain.
I almost forgot to bring my wand.
Arrow.
Does anybody have an extra wand?
I forgot mine.
You forgot a door!
We're leaving that mine.
Oh, I have a wind wand here.
Oh, I got one.
I got a wind wand.
Somebody gave it to me.
I took one.
Wait, wait.
You need me.
I have another one too.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, good, good, good.
I already need one one.
Where is the...
Arrow.
Wait, what do the containers look like, guys?
What are the what?
Containers?
This one?
This yuck.
What do you...
What the container?
You peed in it!
That's fucked up.
Wait, it increased!
Wait, wait.
Arrow!
Do we break it?
Do we get gold?
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna...
Oh.
Nice!
Oh, I increased the value of my piss!
What is this?
I was going!
Will you get more money?
Okay, I'll try to remember not to break those then.
Oh my god.
I didn't think it...
Oh my...
It turned gold.
Just like getting over it.
Is that what's happening to the pot?
Piss, yeah.
Now I have to piss on the...
Is this the thing to...
Oh, well, it's just not.
Oh, okay, and it doesn't work.
Wait.
There was a gold there.
Arrow.
No, I lost...
Oh, there it is.
He-he, stuck in the cushion.
I'm going forward.
I don't trust myself.
I don't trust myself alone.
Because I think it's been like the same...
You peeing over the side?
No, I'm peeing on the paintings.
I'm creasing the valley.
Oh, okay.
Oh, God.
it's over there yeah we don't have any fire though we need
got to find a torch oh yeah we don't have looks on wait what
was that i made a special sound oh no i don't i can't see i
know this game is so dark it is so dark i'm like where are
okay the only way across oh that's that's what oh wait no
Oh, that's, that's Nimi.
Okay, I thought it was a...
Are you really Nimi?
Play us a song if you're the real Nimi.
There's a really not real LIMO, though.
Where?
Wandering the castle.
Oh, that's an eyeball.
Don't touch me, I have to sneeze.
Come on, guys.
Just in respect, vibes.
Is that real?
I'm real.
Oh, you're real.
Okay.
I'm real.
Which way do you want to go?
Oh, let's go up.
Where did our bard go?
Mimi?
She was with you.
Yeah, I thought she was following me.
Wait, piss yuck.
I do not know what to do.
What are we piss yucking?
Oh.
Oh, it like really fills up.
Ew.
It like makes a sound effect and everything.
Oh, there's an eyeball behind you.
See, I have a pillar.
Mimi, are you reading?
Yes, that's real.
Eww!
Oh, you're fine, you're fine.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah.
Disgust!
Eww!
It was filled with pee!
I died on your road.
Eww.
Arrow.
How much HP do you have right now?
56!
You're...
She's still okay.
She's still healthy.
Yeah.
There's an eyeball?
Stay underneath them.
Ah, never mind, don't say underneath him.
It's a fish, it's a fish, it's a fish now.
Yeah, yeah, she is.
Oh, there's a guy behind us.
Oh, I can't hear her.
Oh, no!
Okay, I can turn her into a fish and then it'll reset it.
Does that work?
Fish me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, I hear you now?
Oh, okay.
Hi.
I sneeze at her too.
Wait, this is really expensive.
This thing...
Wait, which one?
Oh.
This big statue.
I would shrink it before and I would break it.
Piss, yuck.
What if I pee on it?
Oh, if I pee on it, I desecrate it.
Either.
Okay, let's just keep going.
It's fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
I still find green containers.
It's okay.
I didn't get hurt.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's okay.
Oh, eyeball, eyeball, eyeball.
Oh, there's a teleporter.
I can't push it.
Oh, achoo.
Ah!
Oh!
Achoo!
Oh, be careful.
Be careful.
hide behind it disappeared okay okay fish yuck i mean piss
yuck please make up your mind i'm peeing i'm peeing on the
statue it is actually yeah i didn't realize it was like just
desecrating everything oh see see see you can get behind it
oh you guys the knight is here oh oh there we are fish yuck
ow fish yuck he's a fish go go go teleport teleport
Teleport!
A fish hug!
Fish hug!
I turned it into a fish, Morty!
When you should ever.
Oh!
Oh, oh.
Those are both.
That's two Limus.
That, yeah, I just saw two Limus, dude.
Those are two Limus.
And they're not destroying...
Wait, what was that sound?
That's a goblin.
Oh.
Oh, he's got a sword.
He has a sword.
Oh my god.
You guys it's it's bad here.
It's bad.
It's bad bad There's a teleporter teleporter over over here
over here Is Nimi okay?
How did you drop your wand?
I don't know he shit.
He robbed you.
He robbed me.
He's a fucking He robbed you.
He robbed you.
Nimi?
Nimi, if you come back downstairs!
Jump down, we'll catch you!
Oh god, run, run, run.
Oh god, oh god, we won't catch you, Nimi!
We have to go!
That guy reminds me of the Pinar Snipper guy.
What?
Snipper guy?
Arrow.
What are you watching?
Nimi?
Arrow.
I don't know.
The goblin stole my...
The goblin stole it.
Wait, go grab that torch.
This one?
Oh my god.
Oh, hello?
Oh, did you just teleport?
Oh, it's not.
Yeah, I was with Lymo and I wouldn't remember...
Wait, wait, did you use that teleport?
Yeah.
Oh, that's where we were gonna go.
Yeah, so I guess it doesn't matter.
Everybody's here.
Oh, everybody's here.
Hi.
We're trying to get Nimi.
Nimi stuck upstairs and I think there's a lot of stuff
upstairs.
Oh, okay.
We hear you, Nimi.
There's something up there.
I hear it.
Wait, I lost him.
We made it!
Guys, we made it!
We did!
But we have to get Nimi.
Yeah, we have to get with Nimi.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, we have.
There's a big thing right there.
what is that there's some baddies over there yeah there's a
bunch of baddies that's not and so we have to grab her
because i'm done make it for the day arrow now that i don't
have faith but i'm just like trying to create a buffer here
yeah yeah yeah yeah just in case all right so all of us
can't die all right i want to go get nimmy though we can do
a recent rescue mission we will rescue her i nothing on me
except for a torch.
Nimmy, if you can hear us, jump down!
Wait, I got a frog!
Wait.
It's okay, guys.
I got a frog.
Wait, is this- What are those?
Is that Mimi?
It says get it, get it.
No, it says get, get it, get.
Why are they following me?
Is that Limo?
You're her new mom.
Eram.
She dead.
She's dead!
Oh shit,
shit!
Oh shit, shit!
I'm okay!
Oh my god, I have 13 HP.
I don't think I'm okay.
Get out of here.
You're not allowed in this room.
in here.
You're not allowed in here.
Get out.
Get out of this room.
Beautiful people only.
Arrow!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You should be about to, like, burn him.
Oh, my God.
You can't even burn this guy.
Yeah, he sucks.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
God, I'm just getting a buffer right now.
Wait, he's up here!
Go, Arrow.
go go away arrow I almost died I have six HP it's all right
I have a frog oh I was more passive income we're gonna be so
rich by then oh she got me funny yeah but it doesn't matter
though because she has to revive her she's coming she's time
no but we might still lose i think it's like minus 80 or
something yeah yeah yeah i don't know how much money
neemie's worth it's pretty good she's coming over i think
she's over here i'm here i'm here i'm bringing the body as
well because i think you lose less money so hopefully we
will have enough yeah oh okay nice i burned lots of things
we saw i can't drag her up here oh no you got Don't you come
up?
Get away?
Get away.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a joint effort.
Joint effort.
Yeah, we can at the knees.
There we go.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, yes.
There we arrow.
There we go.
I start.
Just a little wizard humor.
Up.
Hooray!
Up done!
Yay!
Don't be under the instruction.
We're fine, right?
Yippee!
Yay!
Oh!
385?
No!
Wait, this is kind of fun.
On our last game, we get to see what happens.
Yay!
We sandbagged on purpose.
Yeah, we did it on purpose.
Yeah, obviously.
You can't tell us how to live our lives.
Up dog!
Dog!
Oh no!
I think he squashed us.
You know that's a book.
Precious you.
Yeah.
I heard something wailing in the woods.
Oh, I can't hear you.
Oh, I can hear you.
I can hear you.
Hello?
Well, I'm blue.
Hi!
We lost all our frogs!
No!
I have one right here.
Oh, yay!
Good!
Yeah, I think this is like we're set to Zira basically.
Yeah, we did a good job.
That was fun though!
That was pretty fun.
It's crazy though that he didn't have Fire Spit!
That's kind of cool though.
He has a Fire Spit but it ain't the same as Fire Ball, you
know?
Fire Ball?
No, that shit's basic.
Watch me, watch me, watch me go.
Y'all should we whip?
Dude, dude, look what I can do.
Mr. Beast!
Wait, which one is that?
That's yell.
Yelling?
Mr. Beast!
Live is not having any of this.
Wow!
Put it in selfie mode!
It's even better.
No, no, no.
Oh, did you guys notice that it resets like the audio to 50
as well?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, it does.
Yeah, I was like, yeah, I was like, why is everybody so
quiet?
Oh, you're right, yeah.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that, Evo?
That's just crouching.
I'm bobbing it to the beat.
I thought you were doing an Evo there.
They're so cute.
is fun i appreciate this play i'm pretty sure they're gonna
update this game even more did you see the game that lam was
suggested oh yeah we can do that one too yeah yeah yeah
let's see it's fun i had fun guys thanks for joining thank
you yeah thank you this was so much we have a wonderful
night with us we made it further than i expected good night
good night good night thank you goodbye Bye everyone!
Goodbye!
Bye bye!
Bye guys!
JJ JJ JJ!
The stance so quick!
Goodbye!
Who's a good vibes?
Good vibes, good vibes.
I'm trying to like suspend myself in the air.
Up dog.
I'm learning floatation.
Wait, can you up dog while you're dancing?
I don't think you can.
Oh.
Watch me do the splits.
Okay.
What the?
How did you do that?
You're jumping, crouching, pressing B.
Oh, my God.
Dance lessons are paying off, guys.
That's my finale move, my finishing.
Oh, I just got stuck in the ground.
Woo, GG's.
GG's.
Oh, GG's.
Oh, we are.
My mom.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, guys.
Wait, how do I leave?
Oh.
Wow, that was so silly.
It's really fun when the game doesn't recognize your boys.
But it was very silly, very silly time.
Thank you guys for yapping with us tonight, and yeah, I like
my hat.
Actually underneath it.
You would have never known.
Is it my triangle?
No way!
She was a ghost the whole time.
These games I never feel like i'm good at them but they're
always like fun so i would like to play them every once in a
while thank you guys thank you thank you i'm gonna head out
um oh i was like i have something to do tonight i couldn't
remember what i had i had something that was scheduled for
yesterday but then it got changed to today so i'm gonna go
do that thank you guys thank you you.
My favorite part is when you say a spell and it's not
midway, but it still activates.
I know.
It's so goofy.
Dargo, thank you.
Thank you so much for the pink.
Thank you guys for the super chats, even though it was hard
for me to see mid stream or acknowledge mid stream, but I
appreciate each and every one of you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a good day, have a good night, and I'll see you when I
see you.
Next, it's Rasha'ai!
Otumi-to!
Bye bye!
Thank you!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye!